- Good morning, Believe Nation!
My name is Evan Carmichael.
My one word is believe, and
I believe that entrepreneurs
will solve all of the world's problems.
Today's message is Don't
Care What Others Think.
Over to you Warren Buffett.
(rooster crowing)
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso keep me goin'
- It never bothered me if people disagreed
with what I thought as long
as I felt I knew the facts.
I mean, there's a whole bunch of things
I don't know a thing about (laughs).
I just stay away from those.
So I stay within what I call
my circle of competency,
and Tom Watson said it best.
He said, "I'm no genius,
but I'm smart in spots,
"and I stay around those spots."
Well, I try and stay around those spots
and I just don't have a
problem if somebody says,
"You're wrong on something."
I just go back and look at the facts
and I think that really is
much more important, frankly,
than having a few points of IQ,
or having an extra
course or two in school,
or anything of the sort.
You need emotional stability.
- I really love that last bit
that he talked about, emotional stability.
I think it's really
important for entrepreneurs
to understand where your
threshold is of how much
crap you can take from other people,
how much negativity, how
much feedback and criticism
that you can take without
it impacting your psyche
or your self-worth.
I think, in general, as an entrepreneur
you need to be prepared
to get a lot of crap,
a lot of negativity, a lot
of stuff thrown at you,
and yes, it's easy to say,
don't care what other people think,
but understanding what
your tolerance level is,
and where you kind of
fit on that spectrum,
can really help you design the rules,
so that they're in your favor.
So as an example, there's a guy on my team
who doesn't handle criticism as well.
I'm a lot more comfortable
in the uncomfortable,
where he can bounce around a lot more.
He'll be on top of the
world, like this is great,
and then a negative feedback
comes in and it really impacts
him hardly, and then a
positive one comes in
and he jumps back up, and
so for someone like him,
you can't design as much
risk, as much negativity
or potential negativity so you
got to take a safe path up.
Where for me, I'm more
comfortable in the uncomfortable.
I know that eventually
something's going to work out,
and I know that at the
beginning of any project,
it's going to be rough,
that it may not work out,
that we're going to get some criticism,
and so I'm more willing to jump all in,
in playing that field,
even though it's painful
at the moment because I know
the faster I get through
that pain, the faster I'm going
to come out the other side.
I want that feedback,
and criticism negativity
as soon as possible, so
that I can make it better!
Better for you, better for
me, better for everybody!
And so understanding what
your tolerance level is,
of emotional stability,
how much you can take,
from your friends and your family
and your customers and your
audience and the people
watching you, before your
break, and then being able
to play, just below that limit.
'Cause you can't just play super-safe,
'cause that's not going to make
you happy as an entrepreneur.
But know what your limit is
and playing just below it,
so that it's uncomfortable, it's painful,
but your still going to
be able to get through it,
I think is really important,
that self-awareness,
I think is really important
as an entrepreneur.
So the question today is, I'm curious,
how high is your tolerance
level for taking criticism
from other people?
How much does it bother you
and can you get through it or not?
Really curious to find out.
Please leave it down
in the comments below.
I also want to give a quick
shout out to Leithland Lyon.
Leithland, thank you so
much for picking up a copy
of my book, Your One Word.
I really, really, appreciate the support,
and I hope you're enjoying the read.
So thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to
believe in yourself,
and whatever your one word is,
and I'll see you again tomorrow morning
for another shot of Entspresso!
♫ I wake up every morning
♫ Espresso keep me goin'
(keyboard clicking)
- How did you ignore all
those naysayers and continue
to sort of blaze the trail --
- Well 95 percent of
all new ventures fail,
so if you just bet
against all new ventures,
odds are 90 percent that
you're going to be right,
90 percent of the time,
but, you're going to
miss that one out of ten
or one out of 20 chances
to really hit a home run.
And, I wasn't worried
about the naysayers saying
it wasn't going to work.
I just laughed about it,
because I knew it was.
- And you worked very hard at it as well.
- I wasn't going to let it fail.
And if you read my book, it's right there.
I wasn't going to let it fail,
and I'm not going to let,
I'm not going to let humanity fail
to get rid of nuclear weapons
and handle this energy thing.
I'm going to keep fighting
till we start getting it right.
- [Interviewer] Pay a lot
of attention to reviews
and those kind of things.
- Well, you know, you're
always affected by opinion,
but the more opinions there are of you,
of me, the more, the less I look at them,
because I just can't live my life
based upon what other
people think about me.
So I can't concern myself too much with
what other people think, you
know, it's just not healthy.
I don't think I could continue to do what
I do if I was constantly worrying about
what somebody thought about it.